When it comes to working with others, Unreal takes a different approach to sharing data
and collaborating with teammates through an embedded source control system.
In traditional workflows, the data pipeline is usually decentralized and frequently spread
across multiple servers and departments, each having their own ways of handling data and
their unique files.
DCCs are usually dependent upon using a referencing system to pull data from a central server through
the network in order to work on your file.
If your network is slow, or is being accessed by dozens or even hundreds of personnel, your
productivity can be negatively impacted.
Comparatively, Unreal utilizes an optimized asset file known as the UAsset.
All imported data, whether it's animation, model files, textures, or other pieces of
information are converted into UAssets and stored within the Artist's local content
folder.
Since the data is local to the Artist's machine, access to that data is substantially improved.
So how do you get one teammate's UAsset files to everyone else on the project?
You utilize a central database program like Perforce, Subversion, Git, or Plastic to fetch
or push data back and forth between each artist and a centralized depot.
The epic preferred standard is to use Perforce.
Perforce control prevents any two artists from working on the same file at the same
time, and version control is handled through atomic transactions that prevent data loss.
All alterations or new data is recorded and stored in a change list so that it can be
accessed at any time to recover or revert data.
All of this can be greatly simplified by using Epic's supplied tool known as Unreal
GameSync to help manage change lists and automate many of Perforce's functions.
In traditional pipelines, it's common to see models and animation files tracked by
version numbers.
This is recommended for the original files produced by your DCC, but the exported FBX
data that is brought into Unreal can remain a versionless Source Master.
Unreal is capable of monitoring if the file is updated and can automatically update for
any new exports if they're placed in a folder which is tracked by Unreal, or you can update
it manually.
Your source control system and Perforce will track the changes made to any U asset in Unreal.
If you need to make alternate levels or level sequences, Unreal provides options like duplicating
the level or using the take system in Sequencer.
Just be sure to keep your leads informed.
For dedicated shot tracking, Unreal integrates with Autodesk's Flow Production Tracking,
formerly ShotGrid, or some of you may know it as Shotgun.
Edit plugins will need to be activated within Unreal, and a Flow subscription will need
to be purchased.
USD integration is also available in Unreal through a series of plugins.
Once activated, these plugins will provide access to the USD Stage Actor and Stage Editor.
With Python support, this Pixar-based exchange format will help control selective loading
and unloading of scenes with greater efficiency.